doing good so I like to call this uh
meeting of the subcommittee of uh
Science Tech and energy uh
to order
and we'll start with the Pledge of
Allegiance and I asked Lee oxenham to
lead us in that
clerk to call our role
we have three so I call the five call
the five
four if we don't have you on the list
I'm not a member of the commitment okay
yeah not an official member of the
committee okay you can comment though
very early this morning
I was at a conference
okay
so representative bernati here
myself representative Berna
representative oxen here
representative McGee
and representative McWilliams and
all right that's it
thank you
so the subject of this particular
subcommittee is to discuss whether to
recommend for future legislation or not
recommend for future legislation uh
the items in Senate Bill 259 and what
that that bill does is adds to the
definition of a municipal host uh
political subdivision the state of New
Hampshire
uh housing authorities
quasi-public entities and the peas
Development Authority
so I open this for discussion from any
member of the the public first
oh what's up
all right uh members of the committee as
well as members of our broader committee
any any comments on the appropriateness
of moving this legislation forward
but I do uh I'm getting that way after
retirement watch
but I I really believe that this this
should move forward at least for
discussion I would recommend that the
committee take further action on it
because
we are now where I think everybody is
this morning I saw two people down there
and the governor would say it we're
talking about expanding wind power and I
know in Rockingham County we're talking
about expanding
solar so I think it's very important to
expand our definitions that doesn't
necessarily mean
that they have to but I think that this
is worthy of future action
that's all
yes representative action thank you very
much we discuss this matter in the late
spring a chair votes agree and and his
Works were we need to fix those
so I think it's important for us to go
forward and allow the amendment which we
were not able to pass at that time to
come to the floor of the house in
January so that we can expand this
definition to make sure that we're all
familiar with the with the chart with
the
boundary lines we need to take the
handcuffs and the obstacles off we need
we need to get out of the way so we can
have the expansion of solar wind our
homegrown natural resources for our
energy use and I think this this bill
would be an important vehicle for this
not in its present form but with the
amendment that we discussed uh it could
make a positive contribution so I would
support Passage
recommending that it go forward with the
understanding of the amendment would be
brought forward can I just
yes
we're informal here there's no there's
no we're not we're not by the
um
I don't believe
what you're going to have to do is draft
a whole new piece of legislation for
January and you can't you know
incorporate the amendment or do what you
need to do but you have to draw a whole
new piece of legislation anything that
was in study right now is kind of dead
we'll report out on what we recommend
but a whole new bill has to be brought
in in January and I think that's worthy
of doing
I'm going to add a PS a post-script
governor also mentioned hydroxide so
he's he's really he's really interested
in uh expanding what we need because the
grid is in trouble
I agree I agree we can look at the um
you know and with the amendment which
never was officially brought forward if
I remember correct right because it was
too late or oh it was there but the
prior amendment that had been voted on
and it was not the chair did not
entertain the amendment that's what I
thought I'm trying to remember that I
did say we need to fix yes yes so
so uh
my recollection on this bill is yes we
need to fix it uh this bill is currently
written I agree with representative
Kelly Pitts that this this cannot go
forward as as is currently written uh I
think there was General agreement that
expanding the definition of a political
subdivision to include the states made
sense
and representative oxenhams
comments on dealing with the municipal
boundary issues is another concern that
is relevant for legislative action
um
housing authorities and quasi
development or quasi-public entities and
whatnot was I
I
recollect not much of a of of didn't
didn't have much traction and it
certainly didn't with me because the
definition of what that meant was not
there and
I really am sensitive to to the Whole
Net metering passing costs off from one
group to another
so when it comes to a whole municipality
it's not an issue because everybody in
municipality is benefiting from that
when it comes to the state everybody in
the state benefits from that but if we
start selecting up little subgroups now
it's not as clean so that's kind of
where I am on this
because I drove 110 miles an hour
um I I didn't just say
I want to refer to Rockingham County
which is putting up a 4.9 megawatt solar
array which will take care of the
complex the complex
Dover Stratford county is going to build
a new nursing home
and they have plenty of land out there
they can do something similar
and
take care of that complex so don't uh
don't just
eliminate in your discussion in your
further discussion keep housing
authorities
and counties
in my housing authorities
are in trouble because of the high
electric rates and a lot of those
contracts that they had are going to run
out so keep that in mind and
perhaps you could have some ppos with
those who are usually contained within
the municipality but not really part of
it
so think about that when you when you
move forward but but it in all
move forward yeah I I think those terms
need
cleaner definition because as as you
talked about uh County Services for a
County Complex
where it's all self-contained that's one
thing but
yeah yeah
so which helps everybody yeah
and I do firmly believe that we're going
to be given the data that shows how
valuable solar is to all the repairs
Pair by reducing load so yeah the notion
that we want to be careful about
expanding I think maybe less of an issue
once once we have that data
and the notion that I want to support
firmly and it's expanding our access to
low-cost home-grown resources
and I'm not sure if this is best to help
with that but it has a sufficient
sufficient
beneficial aspects that I would still
support the bill going forward with the
notion that someone could bring forth
and on the floor in January I understand
you can't imagine it
you can't even bring the bill back you
have to write a whole new bill right so
what what we have to recommend is this
this bill is recommended to be brought
forward as further legislation so you
essentially refile it and if we're going
to refile it I would
seriously consider that you fix the
issues in it because so you don't refile
it as as is or we don't recommend as it
is it's recommended for for the
legislation which is where I think this
bill is as is currently written
in this form it's not it shouldn't be
recommended if we're going to go do
something else
then we recommend that whatever that
something else is
I won't be here I
will vote for the one thing that I can
have to say
um
but in the spring yeah
all right well any yes
um the state
was added to the law
um
I don't remember it might have been a
house bill that the senate had where
they added it and then yes yes that was
concurred yeah mm-hmm
yes it is here it was the first
amendment and then this went back to
this or came from the Senate and they
added these other items which are less
well defined that's the problem with
this bill in my mind but the state is I
think very legitimate
so the state we don't have to be
concerned about it with this bill
whether this bill is recommended or it
isn't because it's already been part of
an agreements
I don't have that field number where
that occurred but um
correct
any any further comment
then I would suggest that we vote on
whether we are going to recommend this
bill as it currently exists
to be refiled for or recommended for
future legislation or not recommended as
it currently exists for future
legislation
to call a role first of all I like to
make a I like to make a motion that we
do we do have to do that I make a motion
that we uh
make this considered for future
legislation
okay
committee
all right so now it's all overall
you need to like it myself
yes and Lee yes and Shannon I I will say
no as currently written no okay
motion pass
[Music]
all right uh we have no further business
than this
subcommittee of the
Science Tech energy is uh
complete
no no